it looks damn clear right now it's the
first or second week in June to go into
phase one again that's manufacturing
construction wholesale and retail only
for curbside pickup those are the big
standards and then we'll fill in a lot
of blanks between now and then about how
to do those things and how to approach
them safely but I think it's gonna be
first or second week in June in less and
less people get undisciplined and start
to lose track of their standards and we
start to see a resurgence you could
almost hear all of New York City's
business says with an apoplectic are you
kidding me the New York City Mayor Bill
DeBlasio digging in on dragging a
shutdown out that they say if it were a
linger much longer particularly to when
he wants to do this the first second
maybe third week of June they could be
done entirely New York Democratic
Congress who knocks rows with us right
now congressman what do you think of
what the mayor is saying this is still
some weeks off yeah my friend thank you
so much for having me let's think about
the small business owner right now the
guy who owns a shoe store for instance
that for months has seen the liquor
store open okay it's not as if the
liquor store has some ability to
hypnotize kovat before it comes into its
stores and stop it but the shoe store
owner does it let's be sensible you know
the mayor's comments at this point are
coming off as if he is in elitist
dilettante that does not understand the
struggles of our small business owners
you know we got we can do this
responsibly but we have to have that
sense of urgency around the mom and pops
that have dedicated their lives to their
businesses you know I come from a long
line of small business owners and I
understand just as so many New Yorkers
do that when you own a small business
that's not a nine-to-five so your entire
life and they are watching their small
businesses wither on the vine
we have got to do something let's issue
standards let's distribute PPE you know
massive way and let's start to get this
thing open you know our small business
owners are incredibly smart especially
in New York City and they understand
that 25 percent occupancy rates that's
just the beginning
times are still going to be really
difficult but at least it's a start and
they're deserving of nothing less you're
also United States congressman's are you
gonna weigh in and maybe try to
influence a city mayor because it does
seem to be even stricter than some of
the guidelines were hearing from New
York Governor Cuomo what is he looking
at that others are not I mean even the
incidents the death rates the
hospitalizations all are dramatically
down in the city and all the borough's
so what is he basing this on do you know
well well look I'm I'm not going to
start and say that we shouldn't be
looking at science and we should be
consulting metrics and trusted experts
in this regard but I think that what he
is not looking at which is the critical
thing because we know he's looking at
hospitalizations and this and that but
what he's not looking at is the
potential for a continued economic
nuclear bomb to go off each and every
week in New York City as our small
businesses our mom and pops died today
they're customers right now get to go to
Target their customers get to go to Home
Depot to large supermarkets and
nonetheless they cannot go to the small
businesses it doesn't make sense and all
we're asking for all they are asking for
is some sense of guidance and some sense
of urgency that gives them resources
they're not getting it from the mayor
congressman so let me ask you this some
of them are already opening up so I'm
wondering technically they would be in
violation of the mayor's orders and by
extension the governor's orders for
those who are gonna feel tempted that
the hell with it I'm gonna open up I'm
gonna you know allow sidewalks or
whatever you want
should they be penalized for doing that
look my friend I'm not gonna come on
your show and advocate for anyone
to break the law or go against the
mayor's guidance but what I am coming on
here to say is that this may mayor's
leadership at this point and his tone
death message to our small businesses is
pitiful and this city will be better off
when he is no longer than mayor this is
a enormous disappointment and our
businesses are going to suffer now there
are certain things though that the
federal government can be doing as well
I came out today arguing that the
president United States should assert
the defense production Act to push PPE
down to large small businesses we have
to extend the PPP program past the eight
week deadline to 24 weeks and we
certainly have to get rid of this
ridiculous 7525 ratio because if you're
a small business owner in New York City
look your rent is sometimes 50 percent
of your costs and we have to fix that so
that they can stay open let me ask you
that president today was pushing the
houses of worship open I talked to a
rabbi and a priest on this issue saying
that they will obviously honor
reasonable capacity requirements but
then the mayor's people come out with a
statement saying we'll continue to work
closely with faithful eaters to ensure
people can safely worship during these
stressful times but will not take any
steps that could jeopardize New Yorkers
health well the fact of the matter is
they have not been supporting large
gatherings in churches so there's that
they've never been doing that so
obviously they're gonna continue to
honor what they've always been doing
which is not what the president says
they should be doing should you and do
you have any problem with people of any
faith any house of worship once again
returning to those places of faith even
honoring social distancing and other
guidelines that we see in other states
well absolutely and look I don't think
that this is a decision you know you
look back three months or so the
president I think actually correctly
noted that opening closing should be
decisions made according to decisions by
governor's this as well as a decision
that cannot be made on a national basis
it has to be made in partnership with
faith-based leaders if you look to many
of the leading faith-based organizations
and leaders in New York City I think
there is an overarching consensus that
we're not yet at the point where we can
begin an opening but what we should
start to do is tell people when it will
happen we need you know I remember back
to when I was in Army Ranger School the
worst thing you're our eyes could ever
do to you was put you on a rock March
and tell you and not tell you when it
was gonna end that was what you feared
more than anything else and that's the
place where most New Yorkers are in
right now they've been doing the right
thing their heads have been kept down
and they've saved lives now they have to
be told when times can get better well
put congressmen very good seeing you
again be safe be well be healthy all
right